[Music]
I'm the kind of guy who tends to let
things go yeah that's my personality do
you often if I take a stand with people
and situations like that I do I usually
don't but when I do it's always the most
ill-timed I think for me the one I
always remember of like why should never
stand up for myself I used to live in
Amsterdam like ten years ago I worked
for a theatre in Amsterdam like right
after I caught right out of college and
you would like in Amsterdam you couldn't
hail a cab ten years ago there were like
these taxi lines where people like spill
out of clubs and bars and you wait in
the line of like a hundred people right
and calves blow up it was a mess like
everybody was drunk and it was a
nightmare and then everybody which like
cut in front of line and there was one
time or his next in line and then the
cab pulled up and a guy and his girl
just like jumped in the cab and
something came over me again where I was
like this cannot stand and this is show
out of character for me I reached in and
I pulled the guy out of the taxi you put
your hands on the guy and pulled him out
of the taxi and then he started yelling
at me in Dutch a language I don't speak
now here's the thing in Amsterdam I
found which is if two people were
arguing if one of them was American
everybody would side with the Dutch
person that just makes sense that's only
fair you know one side with the worst
Dutch person over the best American
person right it was like a 20 year old
projectile vomiting and Betty White the
Dutch guy would get the cab yeah so I
was desperate not to reveal that I was
an American so I was speaking the only
Dutch I knew which was know which in
Dutch is nae so the guy was like
speaking to me in Dutch and I just arted
going neh-neh-neh-neh-neh-neh-neh
and then he would make his next point
and I would go nenenene
and while I was doing this I crawled
into the taxi where his girlfriend was
already in the backseat so she was
looking at me and she was talking to me
and then I used another Dutch word I
know because the Dutch word for out is
out so that played right into my
wheelhouse I was going out out out out
nenenene and then finally they gave up
because they were like obviously we're
dealing with a simpleton right those two
words right and she got out and the guy
got out and I was so proud of myself and
I was so happy and we were pulling the
taxi down the street and I should have
just let it go I rolled down the window
and I leaned out and I yelled I claim
this taxi for America yes
[Applause]
you